[Musique]
notre plus gros tournoi de l'année et
prêt à délivrer son verdict
[Musique]
évènement n'a cessé de prendre de
l'ampleur depuis son lancement mais
voyons des milliers de joueurs
s'affrontés pour tenter de se tailler
une part du gâteau d'un million de
dollars
8 finalistes exceptionnels ont en
découdre dans une ultime bataille afin
de déterminer qui remportera les 200000
dollars promis aux vainqueur et le
premier titre de champion de chains.com
de l'histoire avec encore deux bouts
dans l'arène 6 anciens candidats et l'un
des meilleurs juniors du monde la phase
finale s'annonce palpitante l'enjeu
augmentant la durée des matchs est aussi
revue à la hausse les cuits partis
disputés en 15 + 2 au lieu de 4 encore
plus d'excitation et de rebondissements
sont attendus
icarunakamura Diane Christophe Douda
Wesley Sow dimitriandrie muraja BOV
Annie Giri nihalsarine Samse n'ont plus
qu'un objectif en tête
[Musique]
je vous invite donc à suivre cette phase
finale epic en direct depuis Toronto et
Belg pour découvrir qui sera couronné
champion